Ron DeSantis recently pulled the
publicity stunt in Chicago and the
governor of the state of Illinois where
Chicago is didn't like it and he's
firing back and firing back viciously
what happened is that Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis in what appears to be a
pre-presidential run announcement tour
has been going he went to Staten Island
he also went to Chicago and he spoke to
the Fraternal Order of Police Lodge
number seven on Monday night in Elmhurst
which is a suburb of Chicago and at that
event Ron DeSantis went after JB
pritzker the Democratic governor of
Illinois
for his criminal justice policies saying
the safety act and other Illinois
policies are the wokification of Public
Safety now this is an incredibly
inaccurate Claim by Ron DeSantis but JB
pritzker who does not mess around
viciously but accurately attacked Ron
DeSantis take a look at this the truth
is that we we actually have a much
better education system in Illinois than
they have true in Florida we're ranked
higher than they are yes U.S news and
World Report ranks K-12 education in
Illinois sixth in the country and number
one among the largest states in the
country yeah
so he's got nothing to brag about when
it comes to education so uh so he moves
on and tries to use this word woke to
describe everything he doesn't even know
what the word means and he has no
definition of it it's just anything he
doesn't like is wokism true and all I
can tell you is that I don't know what
that means and frankly uh what I can say
about Illinois is that we're a state
that cares about Equity we're a state
that cares about our families that's
woke caring about your family and Equity
that's what he means by woke sir making
the Investments that are required so
that our youngest children will do
better and better and I'm really excited
about the direction of our state as
opposed to a state where they don't make
the Investments that are necessary to
lift up their education system or their
Health Care system so pritzker is of
course completely correct now the tough
talk from pritzker
is being suggested could be because he's
planning potentially to run for
president if Biden doesn't run or maybe
even if he does it's sort of unclear but
pritzker's name has kind of been
floating around as a possible Contender
but put that aside for a second okay
the truth is that even if you put aside
education where Illinois is light years
ahead of Florida that's absolutely the
case put aside talk about the primary
subject matter here remember DeSantis
was speaking to police about law
enforcement and so on and so forth the
Wright loves to talk about the dystopian
war zone that is Illinois because of
Chicago specifically and it's absolutely
true that Chicago does have a
significant gang and gun crime issue
we've talked about how easy it is by the
way to go over the border into Indiana
40 minutes and then go back with uh guns
that you can easily obtain in Indiana
we've talked but put that put all of
that aside for a second despite Florida
having the lacks gun laws and laws that
give police more latitude and all these
different things and despite the
allegation that Illinois is just so
backwards on crime the reality is that
Illinois and Florida have really similar
violent crime rates they have different
populations but if you look at per
capita violent crime it's something like
it's 390 per hundred thousand people in
Florida and 420 per 100 000 people in
Illinois yes Illinois has a slightly
higher violent crime rate but the truth
is they're both right in the middle
around the 2025 you know out of 50
states so to put it a different way
even though if you ask Ron DeSantis
Florida's doing everything right on
crime law enforcement and guns and
Illinois is doing everything wrong on
crime law enforcement and guns they have
almost identical violent crime rates
which really makes you wonder
is Ron DeSantis really doing everything
right is JB pritzker really doing
anything wrong because those are pretty
damn weak numbers to demonstrate that
that's the case good for JB pritzker I
like the guy I am not as familiar with
him as as on policy as I could be but he
has always struck me as decent and
willing to use the sort of language
rhetoric and tone against these lying
Republicans that I think we need more of
and that we've seen from only only a
handful of prominent Democrats let's
take a very quick break all of the clips
I played for you here will be on our
YouTube channel at youtube.com the
davidpackman show and they will also be
on the Spanish YouTube channel for those
who prefer the Spanish language version
of this show
at davidpackman.com Spanish
one of our sponsors today is Bluetooth a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month's supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence when
it's time all you have to do is take a
short quiz on their website a licensed
doctor approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of Bluetooth tablets are made in the
USA the entire process is just a few
clicks go to bluetooth.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code Pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping